otto beckham jr made some news yesterday
both with what he said at his weekly
press conference and what he did back in
january at the national championship
handing out cash remember all the things
lsu said it wasn't real money make money
it was fake money he went out and
collected it back it was just all in fun
and then joe burrow blew the whistle on
everything no it was real it was yeah it
was real money yeah yeah
so otto beckham jr is now banned from
the lsu facilities for the next two
years well it's not like he was going to
be back
over the course of the next year anyway
because of the pandemic and and and and
look i yeah i i it the whole thing is
ridiculous all it does when something
like this occurs is it shines an even
brighter light on a corrupt system that
does not give the players fair value for
their skills abilities and sacrifices
and also the risks they take physically
yeah
that's the reality and and i've i've
done the full 180 in the course of my 20
years of being in this business because
i was drinking the kool-aid that this is
a violation of the rules it needs to be
taken seriously i remember the whole
reggie bush thing and god forbid that
his family get free rent from an agency
group that wanted to represent him god
forbid he got unfair benefits indirectly
look get what you can while you can i
say that to every kid out there that is
playing sports at the college level and
getting room board tuition fees and
snacks
get what you can while you can because
they're making a ton of money off of
your effort and they don't care so you
get what you can while you can yeah
period yeah mike i mean i know we see it
the same way we really do and you know i
don't know why odell had to do it right
there in front of all the cameras and
everything that's going to be set for
discretion yeah that might have been the
the biggest mistake he made um but
you're right it's not going to affect
his life okay wow yeah he's not going to
lsu any time soon anyways and you know
again it's i'll state something i've
said this crap's going on everywhere
every school everywhere now like i said
it's not happening on the field in front
of cameras and everything like that but
they just it's unstoppable so i i just i
don't even care that he did this it
means nothing to me and it means i don't
look at lsu any worse off or anything
like this there was plenty of other
games or other schools or trust me the
players were in the parking lot they saw
an alumni and they got a big handshake
of cash all right that's just the way it
goes down and i got no problem with that
so
that's it
and i've been hearing those stories for
years too you know at programs where
guys who don't even play exactly they
they get their tickets they're two
tickets free tickets to every game and
they sell them to someone at a dramatic
there's another one nobody ever nobody
ever knows the difference exactly and
that's the thing because it doesn't
happen on camera
that was the big mistake yeah so i i
look it it's it's really nice how much
money you think he had in that wad of
cash there how many how much you think
he had five grand 10 grand the school
said it was 2 000
but who but who knows well he gave out
two thousand dollars that means it
doesn't mean he gave it all away you
know but that's what i think he kept
some of it well i don't know he had he
probably had a night out where he wanted
to have some fun i mean he's there in
louisiana on you know
you know uh what the hell is that the
french quarter and everything like that
i'm sure he had to keep some cash for
himself i guess i don't know
when he spoke to reporters yesterday he
addressed his demeanor at the end of the
blowout laws to the pittsburgh steelers
and he said that
he's he's not going to make any
apologies for getting upset when they
lose he wants to win he wants to win
every game and he's not going to give up
until the game is over and he said you
know because we saw him remove his
cleats well the coach took him out of
the game right and for his own good he
wasn't putting him back in and and he
said he's had a lingering turf toe issue
since the the cowboys game so he was
taking the cleats off yeah
he he's not going to keep his foot bound
up in this tight cleat any longer than
he has to so yeah and he also and this
one's funny to me
he didn't say the name but i know who
he's talking about a guy that he very
much would like to play with who's
currently the quarterback of the tampa
bay buccaneers i'm kind of over trying
to play the right thing because i love
him to death but there are people who
have plenty of rings and are considered
the goat and they do things on the
sideline and other people do things on
the sideline and they get away with it
yeah and that's classified as passionate
because they may have something behind
their legacy or whatever it is i don't
care if i have zero rings 12 rings or 20
rings i love this game of football and
i'm not going to keep dulling myself for
the world to feel like i am mature or
whatever you would like me to throw
around it i am always going to be me
tired of losing tired of losing to good
teams just ultimately want to win and
you know what's most telling there tired
of losing to good teams yeah see that's
where the browns are this is why it
feels like the browns are two and four
not four and two they're beating the
teams they should but they're still
getting blown out by the teams that are
better than them and that's what i think
is driving odell beckham jr crazy he
wants them to be competitive with
everyone they've had the ravens they've
had the steelers 38-6 38-7 they're not
ready to compete with the best two teams
in their own division no no yeah you're
right he he knows you know not that he's
been on super bowl teams but he was on a
playoff team there in the new york
giants with super bowl
people as in tom coughlin and eli
manning and he understands that it's got
to be to another level as far as yeah
you want to start to beat the good
football teams you know that's going to
take another level of intensity
preparation attention to detail you know
so that's where i think he is frustrated
and this is quite honestly the reason
i'm an odell beckham jr defender and all
these things has he crossed the line a
few times through his career certainly i
understand that i do
but what i saw you know up here in new
york throughout his whole career
was more times or not a guy getting mad
because they were losing football games
or yes they're losing a football game
and he's the best player on the team and
he hasn't touched the ball the first
four series of the game you know that's
to me and it wasn't because it was like
me me me me i want to touch the ball
he's more like you explained it the
other day what the hell we're losing and
we're losing and we're not giving me the
ball that makes no sense every
wide receiver in the history of the
sport would do some of the stuff he did
now he's he's commercialized he's a
superstar
everybody looks at every little thing he
does and yes he did cross the line maybe
with some of those antics i understand
that but jerry rice tyrell owens it
doesn't matter who you talk about if
those things went down they were going
to come over to the sideline and let
everybody know what the hell is going on
here
think about jerry rice and i've heard
this time and again
the pr staff in san francisco when he
was playing did a very good job of
anticipating when he was going to blow
his stack right and getting him hiding
the locker room before he could right
and uh that gets back to what we talked
about with ryan fitzpatrick why do you
put this guy in front of a microphone
yesterday they knew when to avoid
microphones for jerry rice and when to
get him out of the building right after
the game so that the reporters wouldn't
have access to him and otto beckham jr
he just is who he is and he's right we
see tom brady blow a gasket and it's not
like we don't call it out it's not like
we don't point it out i mean brady got
relentlessly criticized two weeks ago
for the right four finger thing and and
for for for yelling at ryan jensen but
but uh yeah what's the difference it's
passion it's wanting to win and that's
what oto beckham has here's where we
need to give otto beckham jr some praise
and this is unfortunate because he had
some comments about covet 19 and i saw
what ultimately made the headlines on
twitter yeah he said somewhat flippantly
i don't think covert can get to me i
don't think it's going to enter this
body i don't want any parts of it it
doesn't want any parts of me i think
it's a mutual respect he had kind of a
half smile on his face as he said that
and this all flowed from the fact that
he got sent home last week for a couple
of days because he wasn't feeling well
and he had to pass some covet tests
before he could come back and his point
was i didn't have it
but what he said after that i think
merits attention and praise because
he didn't feel well and it wasn't like
somebody came up to him like jake
d'alone to you after that game in
september of 2006 and said you don't
look so good right he went to someone
and said i don't feel so good so they
activated the protocol that required
them to send him home from practice on
thursday practice on friday he had to
have multiple negative cova tests before
he could come back
he did the right thing and he said and
here's the quote
it was more in my mind for me and my
maturity level i felt like it was the
right thing to do to mention i may have
not been feeling well i wouldn't want it
to spread throughout the whole building
if there was a case that i would
possibly have had it i was trying to be
an adult and precautious about the
situation and trying to handle it the
right way
that's what he needed to do that's what
football players need to do yeah and the
problem is as we see more of these guys
get sent home because they say man i'm
not feeling right today or oh by the way
my wife's got covert 19.
more and more guys are going to keep
their mouths shut
and and it's the selfish thing to do he
did the selfless thing he took himself
out of circulation for two days of
practice because just in case yeah he
does have it he doesn't want it to get
through the facility and maybe end up
infecting someone that it's going to
potentially kill definitely so
that's what should have been the
headline for moto beckham jr yesterday
because that's the behavior we need to
see other players emulate because i
guarantee you other guys aren't doing it
they're not lining up to say what their
symptoms are in a given day and and
knowing that they're going to get sent
home and maybe ultimately benched
because their replacement comes in and
plays well yeah well you know the first
thing that just comes to mind is this is
where like you just can't win as a
professional athlete sometimes in this
day and age anymore you just can't win
either way you go you know oh he does
the mature responsible thing oh you know
and he gets backlash for that okay so
then what if he stayed and he did have
covet and now let's say 10 guys came
down with it and all of a sudden it's
the biggest game of the year brown
steelers and they can't play everybody
be going oh odell beckham jr you're such
an immature idiot
i can't believe he did that he's just
thinking about himself all the time so
you know what do you want yes he did the
responsible thing you know he's showing
leadership with that football team and
he's you know i like everything he said
yesterday i did i do i do but i hope it
can be more of a good example type thing
for other players to just look at and go
wait odell beckham jr can do it then
okay i can do it too and go there and
tell the coaches or whatever i don't
feel well but it could go either way to
your point because maybe it'll scare
people too
but i think ultimately doing the right
thing is something that needs to be
celebrated he did the right thing it's
it's unfortunate that he tried to make a
joke that wasn't all that funny and that
people locked onto those words out of
context and didn't consider the full
quote and understand that he was
acknowledging he could get it that there
was a chance he may have had it and
that's why he tapped out and well he was
doing the gardner minshew thing right
the virus want to know once
right he did the same
thing beckham jr so people all of a
sudden make it into something else
we thought it was funny when gardner
minshew said it and people were acting
like it wasn't funny when odell said he
was clearly trying to make a joke but i
think he did the right thing and i
appreciate it even if no one else does
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports